mi dica questo glielo dico subito Questo
è un valore di
€59 si voleva fare un autoregalo di
Natale che carina no signora non ne
abbiamo di più economici anti economico
Qui c'è ben poco forse ho sbagliato
boutique Ma se vuole può aspettare i
saldi non le posso dire se andrà in
sconto o meno sono informazioni che non
possiamo assolutamente rivelare non
insista se le interessa tanto passi
durante i saldi così scoprirà da sola se
andrà in sconto o meno arrivederci a lei
no ma meno male che Natali sono tutti
più buoni ma una maleducazione senza
fine sono senza parole se ha bisogno Mi
chiedo pure questo viene €27 è un po'
caro ma senta che morbidezza è una
nuvola se voleva spendere un po' meno
abbiamo questo che mi è sempre un 80%
lana Eh che taglia le servirebbe mi
faccio controllare se ce n'è ancora un
in magazzino Eh Arrivo subito cioè
Purtroppo ce l'ho solo onl Ma chi lo
dice a me comprare online proprio non
piace io quando compro devo toccare
vedere annusare per un regalo di Natale
no a posto signora allora viene a
gennaio che con i soi se lo prende
almeno almeno almeno almeno il 40%
Facciamo così signora lei mi lascia il
suo numero di telefono appena il
maglioncino mi va in Sago io le faccio
un colpo di telefono Ci mancherebbe
buona giornata